I'm joining the meeting and it's set up.
Я думаю, транскрипция идет довольно хорошо с вашей стороны.
С вашей стороны?
Я думаю, это потому что вы говорите в английском, это переводится на английский, что я не уверен, как это работает.
Я отправил сообщение в чате, чтобы проверить, работает ли это, я не уверен, появилось ли это с вашей стороны.
Просто сообщение разъем на две части.
Справа у вас русский, и он автоматически переводится на английский слева.
А второе сообщение просто английский слева, но оба из них, кажется, работают.
The meeting, I think that worked well.
I mean, the translation was, yeah, like you said, it was a bit delayed.
Some parts of it were a bit off.
The chat function seemed to work very well, though, in terms of its translation.
And, yeah, I mean, I think it worked well overall.
Did see in the meetings earlier, when you're in a meeting,
you can click on someone's profile and add them to your contacts.
But I don't see anything to do it in the user page.
Should just join the previous one.
You can see the channel in my channel section.
Yeah, that's worked perfectly.
- Вы хотите мне сделать то же самое? - Да, я вижу, что это произошло. - Да, это не произошло для меня. - Да, я вижу, что это произошло в английском языке, но произошло.
Знаете, болеть. Я вижу записку. Просто открываю ее. Я была на русском и переведена как это было правильное решение. Она исчезла из моего чата.
- Ну, я думаю, что это было правильное решение. - Ну, я думаю, что это было правильное решение. - Ну, я думаю, что это было правильное решение.